hi I'm Mandy trod I am a senior data
scientist at cyber ax incorporated this
is my email and my Twitter I also happen
to be co-founder of women data
scientists DC which is a meetup group
here in DC for women who are data
scientists women who want to be data
scientists and supporters of women in
data science so I expect you all to join
this is my talk data sciencing while
female my talk is split up into three
pieces the first part is a year in the
life of the data science meetup group
I'm going to talk about the first year
of women data scientist DC and then I'm
going to do a little data science on
data scientists and the final piece of
my talk is going to be about being the
only female data science scientist on a
data science team so women did a
scientist DC like I said is a meetup
group for women who are data scientists
women who want to be data scientists and
supporters of women in data science it
was co-founded by me and Jackie causal
July first or in July of 2050 and as of
October 2015 we became part of data
community DC which is a group of data
science meetups in DC it has his seven
groups currently and it was amazing that
we were able to join with data community
DC it now has over 16,000 members in
data community DC which is amazing and
in March 2016 we added mirov yavka as
one of our co-organizers she also
co-founded data society anybody heard of
data society and WDS DC now has over
1,200 members as of a few minutes ago it
was 12 27 and we are just over a year
that's amazing I'm I'm lemming explosion
happy
and if you're old enough to get that I
love you you can visit our meetup page
at meetup.com / women data scientists DC
or follow us on twitter at women data
side and we've been tweeting a huge
amount today for pi data and you can
also read our blog which isn't posted to
as much as I would like I'm sorry for
that at the data community DC website in
our first year we had a bunch of
different types of events we had talks
from amazingly talented female data
scientists like Lauren Lorenz who spoke
earlier today and Jennifer Starke who's
going to speak tomorrow we had workshops
to learn Python or our concepts we had a
workshop for Python pandas last October
and a workshop for introduction to shiny
in last September and we're actually
bringing it back in two weeks so
introduction to shining meet up coming
up on October 19th I'm teaching it and
we already have 41 people rsvp'd for it
start exciting we had networking events
like our Christmas party in december and
our career meetup in January where
everybody set goals as to what they
wanted to do with their data science
career by the end of the year and we had
speakers from different sectors talk
about what they did is data scientists
what they liked what they disliked and
then we all brainstormed how people are
going to get from really were to where
they wanted to be at the end of the year
we had some amazing inspirational
speakers like Amy O'Connor from Cloudera
and Claire gollnick who is the chief
data scientist at terbium and we have
also had a hack of one where we
collaborated with octo on traffic data
and dave cook from octo came and helped
us figure out what the data what each of
the columns in the days that meant and
we all
collaborator together in Python and our
to analyze the data it was it was
amazing next I'm going to talk a little
bit about data science on Dave
scientists and who all knows our and
shiny hey some people know ok so r is an
amazing statistical programming language
and I love our and the one of the
packages in ours called shiny shiny
allows you to create browser based
applications that allow you to visualize
things that have our statistical
background so it's awesome I created a
nice little shiny on data science
meetups so we're going to go do a life
and then um this shiny is available and
via shiny apps I oh so it's public
anybody can go to it the first tab of
the shiny looks at the state membership
4wds DC for the first year
as you can see what's going on
okay as you can see and we had members
from over 21 states in the first year
even though this group is based in DC
you would expect that most of our
members come from DC so you can go in
here and click on DC 545 members from DC
277 members from Virginia and 175 from
Maryland and that all makes sense
because DC Virginia and Maryland will be
coming to our meetups however we have 11
members from California 10 from New York
3 from Texas and two from Washington
State and others from other states on
this map you can go and click on each
one and get the membership and the map
was created using the package leaflet
which allows you to use the leaflet
JavaScript package and create is really
nice interactive maps
the second tab has membership data for
the all of the DC to meet ups for the
first year
as you can see the the green line here
is WDS DC and is the second fastest
growing meetup in DC to this first
fastest growing meetup is data viz DC
and they only beat us by about thirty
members in their first year which is
kind of amazing and all of the other DC
to meet ups didn't quite come close
and last but certainly not least put
together a heat map of the overlap
between all of the DC to meet ups and
WDS DC overlaps the most with DC data
science DC which happens to be the
largest and data science meetup in DC
too but second overlap the most ways to
data viz DC so a lot of our members go
to data viz DC and data science DC which
is awesome and the code for this meetup
is art for this shiny is also on github
you're welcome to download play with
edit fixed make changes all that now I
come to the last part of my talk and
this talk this part of my talk is for
the women who are the only data
scientists on their team and their
colleagues and their managers does how
many people do not fall into those
categories
okay well hopefully this is entertaining
anyway so my experience being the only
female was on two different data science
teams once at l-3 data tactics and
currently at my company cyber
incorporated at l-3 data tactics I was
contracted out to a program at a
government agency that had a data
science team and the data science team
consisted of 40 data scientists from
three different companies I was the only
female for the first 11 months now one
out of 40 means that I was three percent
of the team and that's rounding up 0a
2.5% and the industry women are twelve
percent of data science so that's Darryl
just saying at so critics however the
data science team consists of four other
data scientists and for cyber experts
and I've been the only female for eight
months one of the data scientist is a
chief data scientist so I'm since he
wasn't on my level or he isn't on my
level I'm not counting him in my math so
I am one fourth of the day of science
team so that makes me twenty-five
percent which is a lot bigger than
industry average was I'm very very proud
of and I started eight months ago so
I've been the only female day of
scientists freight next now being the
only female Dave scientist I try not to
worry about so many things but not
wearing is very hard to do especially
for me if you know me I mean I got here
15 minutes early for my talk some days I
just wear my toe boots
I blast music
my angry girl music
and tell myself I'm kick ass until I
start to believe it here are some of the
things I try not to worry about and this
is for the colleagues and managers also
for the single data science females
because so you know you're not alone
you're not the only one that worries
about these things am I asked to do
certain things because I'm talented or
because they are things women are
normally normally excel at am I being
aggressive enough with my ideas am i
whispering them too much so that other
people steal them or am I being too
aggressive and my coworker calls me a
[ __ ] if I mess up will people use it as
grounds to say women aren't good at data
science and if I say some of the same
things as the guys will there be a
double standard now I have to say that I
worried about things these things way
more when i was one of 40 than i do when
i went up for and even working at a
great company with an amazing team being
the only one is still hard sometimes
these are my guys I'd say breaks I don't
they didn't know until today that i
called them my guys hopefully that makes
them really happy otherwise oh well are
there any questions
yes that's the only female on teams for
so long do you have like one piece of
advice you'd get to the rest of us out
there might find herself in similar
situations I recently adopted a mantra
which helps me a lot whenever I start to
worry about something I say I should
worry about things that I shouldn't
worry about things that I can't control
I can only control me me and me alone
and that helps it helps a lot it also
helps that I voice my opinion on things
when I want something to change because
if I don't say anything they don't
change and if you're at a place where
you can't voiced that opinion here at a
bad place jobs it feel obvious that you
were going to be the only woman did you
select that company because this so
that's that's that's a good really good
question I neither actually so the first
time I interviewed i interviewed with
mike so the person who is my current
boss was actually my boss at l-3 data
tactics as well and so he was the one
who actually partially inspired me to
start WDS DC and so it was kind of a
no-brainer to follow him to cyber eggs
but when i interviewed with him I it
wasn't in person it was over the phone
and I had no idea that I was going to be
the only data only woman on the data
science team at the government contract
that I was at and but I at the time I
was coming from academia and I didn't
even think about that
yeah she said that they're twelve
percent of data scientists are women in
industry hmm why are there so few women
data scientists in addition industry so
I would propose that that because data
science is new and most of the tech
field is more dominated by men already
that men adopted data science faster
than we did and I I've done a lot of
work with outreach for women in science
I used to be part of the Association for
women at math and for girls in science
and something happens between middle
school and high school where girls are
just not encouraged as much to go into
science and tech and so it hurts our
percentages further down the line I'm
working really hard to try and change
that and i would suggest everybody else
do the same
yeah ah maybe you're going to get this
big mention to an outreach efforts the
even part of one thing that I see a lot
that I find a little frustrating is
outreach efforts that perpetuated in
your stereotypes so any more with
leaders because they're more intuitive
where they're more or standing or
therefore they list better right okay
and i read that sometimes hurts more
than it helps and you seen 10 wines they
can really like where you've got good so
I I would say that my favorite tag line
is we need more diversity in tech and
data science because diversity just
means that everybody thinks differently
and we have many outside the box
opinions and because I was the only
woman on a day science team I'm kind of
holding up the flag for women in data
science but I would as much hold up the
flag for increasing diversity just
generally
let me decide what sort of moments or
comments to let go and just deal with
and which ones to say something though
um that is a really good question
unfortunately I'm kind of of the mind at
the moment that I say what I feel like
and I regret it later luckily I have an
amazing team that puts up with that for
me um and they'll just tell me if I'm
being annoying or if that just went too
far but when I was at when I was at my
other team I was working for a
government agency and you had to be
extremely professional a lot of the time
I would go in the bathroom and scream
and luckily since I was the only woman I
was the only one ever in there it is
really hard to figure out what you're
going to let go and which are not going
to let go and that is something i don't
think i've perfected yet so maybe ask me
in 10 years cool
yeah chase you achieve you've been
working some Eddie watt absolutely so
when I was at l-3 and realized that I
was a only one I went to my boss and I
said I would like you to well I went to
my boss and said I would like you to
hire more girls because that I'm the
only one and I don't like being the only
one and he said well I would love to but
I can't find them and I called [ __ ]
on that except for I went to go try and
find them and I couldn't find them
either which is what inspired me to
start WDS DC so I went right back into
his office and said ok can you help me
help me with this and sponsor and he's
like sure so that was amazing currently
it's I breaks they give me they sponsor
WDSU see all the time for meetups
anytime I need help and anytime I need
help with it I asked and i usually get
somebody to help
well it yeah how can people get involved
with women day scientists DC like how
like if someone has a tote can they
email me email me tweet me call me beat
me if you want to reach me I don't have
a beber but um I anybody Kim Possible
fans loved Kim Possible anybody who
wants to talk or participate or sponsor
or dot dot dot with WDS DC I welcome any
help I can get and Jackie does too and
so I'm sure so does merope who is our
other coworker nighter for those of us
who are job hunting and want to be those
women that no one can find like looking
hey tries to connect with them so WDS DC
has a job board on our meetup site and
we offer anyone who wants to post a job
on our job board can post and since we
are part of DC to I should plug dateable
and DC to has a web app where you can
submit your information if you're
looking for a data science job and
companies can sort the impossible
candidates by all the different things
like skills and clearance and education
level and the amazing thing about the
dateable app is that all the names are
scrubbed and so you pick your candidates
based on skills and skills alone and
then you get their names and there is a
cost for an introduction but it's a lot
less than the data incubators are
charging for recruiting
how am I on time it's 420 kid so oh my
goodness I talked really fast I'm sorry
guys are there any other questions so
when you are learning about a new topic
or whatnot and have questions help you
feel confident asking then when you're
not sure everyone else knew Lavar
doesn't answer that's a good question
and so I actually am on the other team I
spend a lot of time reading and trying
to figure out things for myself instead
of asking questions because I didn't
feel comfortable asking it because there
were a couple people in the team that
would make me feel really stupid when I
didn't know something and it definitely
wasn't the majority of the team but just
a few ruined it for me but currently the
team that I'm on is amazing and as soon
as I don't know something i asked the
room and nobody treats me like I'm 3
inches tall when I don't know something
half the time they're all like um yeah I
don't know any I have to google that so
yeah he returned to me reaching out for
people to sponsor your group or to
attend an event has been a really good
responsibility so sponsorship has been
an amazingly good response I think we
just started asking people to sponsor
like specific events in May or June May
this may I think was me and because i
was thinking on his shoe string budget
and not getting anything for meet ups so
didn't they usually didn't cost anything
before that and now i realized that
people will come if you have food and so
but people have been amazing with
sponsorships in fact invincea labs for
this last meetup just volunteered to
sponsor food with really out me asking
so that was amazing speaking speakers
that is a little bit harder and but not
a but but still not like impossible we
have had lots of people volunteer speak
and sometimes speakers do drop out its
last minute and then we have to find a
new speaker at the last minute and but
um it's it's not as hard as I think it
would be if I was throwing a conference
to meet ups they're not as much of a
pressure it's not as much pressure when
you're presenting at a meetup
so you notice that are not locally able
to see how do they participate so they
get emails from us and some of our
meetups are live streamed or not live
strange but they're recorded and then
put up on YouTube later and DC 2 is
working on being able to live stream all
of the DC to meet ups and and they have
some new technology that's doing doing a
really good job and when they're able to
get it to the meetup the a lot of the
members that are in other states I
believe that we met through things like
I went to start a Hadoop last year and
announced WDS DC at the diversity lunch
and I know that the people from Ohio and
North Dakota joined that because they
wanted to start a group like WDS DC
there and people from I suspect the
people from California and Georgia are
people from my company cyber X but have
because we have offices in Georgia and
California and otherwise hoping that
we're going to do better about live
streaming events and that people can
participate from anywhere
yeah this is a Python conference you
talk for a minute about by ladies so
this is kind of a sticking point for me
pie data's not Python only prayer data
is for Python our Jupiter and spark but
originally started out to be just Python
because most data scientists were using
Python which is why I presented an are
shiny but i would have to give the floor
over to jackie to talk about pi ladies
because i'm not affiliated with pi
ladies hey we're cool edges yeah hi
ladies I think there's about 70
organizations around the world give or
take now it's really decentralized so if
somebody wants to start of chapter they
set up their own chapter we're about up
to a hundred now in the DC chapter and
it's sort of sheltered and worked as a
lot of work with the Python software
foundation hi ladies is actually now
looking for organization organizers help
i've been onboarding some the organizers
just sort of pass it off to other people
because because women data science DC so
I love both but I only have so much time
so but yeah so we are generally hosting
monthly but we have you know the same
issues that other folks have to with
spaces and speakers and that kind of
thing there's another woman in North
Carolina Julia elman who she and I are
working on a side project to try to
solve some of these faces assault solve
some of these problems to be able to
hook up sponsors and spaces
here is that kind of thing also
encourage people who don't speak to
become a resource to speaking what's the
mission of pilot wings would increase
diversity in Python so it was started by
I think five women in la a DC was a
second chapter and we were just like
let's create another one can we do that
and they were having some conversations
amongst themselves that may not have
been an agreement not about us starting
with just about other things so we're
like okay we're just going to do that
anyways and then they started to like
help us and that kind of thing and we
grow into a much bigger organization and
I could also see I don't know Mindy and
I haven't really talked about this I
could also see that happening with women
data science DC surprise you mean
growing to other states yeah oh um I
know we took the name from somebody else
no we didn't no no we did it I thought
there was somebody else with a similar
name so there was a women data
scientists or San Francisco woman data
scientists and then there was there was
um or no it's San Francisco women of
data science okay so it was similar but
not saying but I could see like taking
and growing the brand and then having
like a larger organization world
domination of WDS I hope that that's
such a question yes okay another
question I here sir quite a few job
living room and I wonder if you know if
you had to give a message towards the
guys who are in data science who want to
you know and
ensure that there's work open spaces
where where women can enter data science
and learn and you know p colleagues
where it's more than one person 19 what
what sorts of advice you know advice or
tips or I don't know any kind of things
that you think men can do to enhance the
environment for their women colleagues
that's a really good question so I'm
really lucky in the team that I'm on
treats me like a person and not gendered
and that's amazing and they respect me
for the things that I like and I don't
like and the my behavior most of the
time and so I would suggest that you
treat the women colleagues as people and
not necessarily women and definitely
don't pull a what's his face from
Silicon Valley I can't remember his name
the guy that nobody calls by his real
name anybody remember there's big head
no
but nobody calls him by his real name
they call them like Brad or Ben or Bill
Gates No yeah the business guy the
pivoting guy Jarrett that one so don't
pull a Jared and try to make try to be
all super excited that you have a woman
when you just treat her like a person
and a talented person especially if she
has talent but I I I guess like I
wouldn't say I I don't want special
treatment I want to be treated just like
everybody else
just with respect that's all and so I
answer your question any other questions
okay well um thank you guys